i want you to write this down i need to  embrace the suffering you know there's  something powerful that once you just  sort of embrace the fact that in order  to achieve something big you've got to  get rid of these distractions and then  the other layer of it is you're probably  going to have to have some suffering to  get there or some sacrifice to get there  and so once you've embraced and decided  that this suffering this sacrifice  you're making is an indicator of  progress it's an indicator of obsession  suffering and sacrifice and hard work  is an indication of progress towards our  dreams the lack of sacrifice the lack of  suffering in our lives its removal its  non-existence  also equates to a non-existence of a  great life a non-existence of a dream  happening a big one anyway and so  embrace the fact that you're gonna have  to sacrifice and suffer to some extent